Es ist wirklich mysteriös 2016 muss mehr als 20 us diplomaten quasi aus gruber fliehen
2018 das gleiche in china auf sie alle waren wirklich geheimnisvolle anschläge verübt worden das ganze hat wirklich das zeug zu einem
spionagethriller denn niemand hatte auch nur einen blassen schimmer was die furchtbaren schmerzen
kopfschmerzen schwindel sprachstörungen und sogar hirnschwellung und nasenbluten
hervorgerufen hatte sie hörten seltsame geräusche und dann kamen die seltsamen symptome jetzt scheint es geklärt krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die us-regierung tab bis heute im dunkeln bei einer anhörung konnten die vertreter der regierung nur mit den schultern
zucken zitat die us regierung kennt keine waffe sei es ultraschall oder
anderes die die effekte hervorrufen können wie sie bei den patienten aus kuba beobachtet wurden
doch jetzt ist eine medizinerin der university of california in san diego wohl auf die lösung der mysteriösen symptomen
gekommen
beatrice golomb scheint die lösung für das rätsel zu haben zitat ich habe mir angeschaut was bisher über die effekte gepulster
radio und mikrowellen bekannt ist und ob dies zu den symptomen der diplomaten passt und es passt
gepulste strahlung im bereich von 2,4 bis 10.000 megahertz kann
geräusche im ohr erzeugen die einen klicken summen klopfen oder zum thenen ähnlich wie es die
diplomaten berichtet haben so die wissenschaftlerin durch die strahlung wird das ohr mit gehörgang trommelfell hörschnecke und so weiter aufgeheizt
wodurch genau solche geräusche erzeugt werden die dann im ohr
selbst entstehen dieser feier effekt entsteht auch in der nähe von starken rabe anlagen und von hochfrequenz sendern
zitat wir haben solche symptome aber auch schon in den tagen des kalten krieges gesehen als die sowjets die us-botschaft in moskau
mit solchen strahlen traktierten so der
umweltmediziner david carpenter von der university of albany er war nicht an der studie beteiligt aber
noch mehr passt zum einsatz von mikrowellen waffen zitat auch die schlafstörungen
kopfschmerzen und kognitiven ausfälle passen ins bild selbst die in
hirnscans nachgewiesenen veränderungen stimmen mit dem überein was für mit radio oder mikrowellen bestrahlt personen berichtet wird ob sie
sprich die us diplomaten sind mit an sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit mit mikrowellen waffen bestrahlt worden
und da mutet es schon etwas seltsam an dass sich die
us-regierung so dumm stellt oder es ist sogar absicht denn die usa forschen seit rund 15 jahren
genau an solchen waffen vielleicht wollen sie sich dabei nicht in die karten schauen lassen alles schon sehr mysteriös wir halten euch auf dem laufenden
also aber nicht vergessen und jetzt clixoom wird werbefrei keine briefe mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung von jeweils einem video im monat ab bald ist es beim ersten video soweit
werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien einen riesen dank an all diejenigen die schon dabei sind
wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor allen andern von mir persönlich auf euer handy
einfach hier draufklicken und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch darauf glichen die erste laserwaffe der welt bis dann
bleibt dran